-That's what I'm talking about.
Paul Shaffer, right there.
The World's Most Dangerous Band.
-What a trip.
This is surreal to be here
after all this time.
-I'm so excited that you're here
and thankful that you're here.
But this is --
When was the first time?
This has been, what?
-Well, you know,
this is such a coincidence
that we're here tonight,
because 41 years ago
this very week
was when David Letterman
came on the air right here,
right across the hall
here at NBC --
-Is that right?
-...with "The Late Show With
David Letterman."
-Oh, my gosh.
-So, this is, like,
our 41st anniversary
that we're celebrating.
And thanks to you,
I have reunited the entire band
from "The Letterman Show."
We're all here.
-Yes!
That's what I'm talking about.
-All the favorites.
-Boys and girl, and we're just
having the time of our lives,
thanks to you.
-When David Letterman
first started,
he started
as a morning show, right?
-That's right, yes.
-And he asked you
to be the musical director?
-I got the call from him
to do "The Morning Show."
It was right after
"Saturday Night."
I had done
the first five seasons
of "Saturday Night Live"...
-That's right.
-...as a pianist and a little
bit of performing and writing.
And then I got a call.
David Letterman
is going on the air
at 10:00 in the morning, live.
And I -- I turned it down.
I turned him down.
-You turned it down? Why?
-I did.
-Why?
-Couldn't get up that early.
[ Laughter ]
But No --
-Why, yeah, of course.
-It just didn't seem --
I don't know.
You know, but luckily for me,
when that show didn't happen,
they gave him another shot.
They gave him "The Late Show,"
the 12:30 spot.
-Yeah.
-And they called me again.
And this time, I had the sense
enough to say yes.
And you know,
here we are, 33 years later
between the two networks.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You know what --
I thought about you,
and I was so happy.
When I used to do Letterman --
First of all, I was a big fan.
I watched his show.
I watched "Late Night"
all the time.
And I love Dave Letterman.
He's a genius, so funny.
But I remember
when I did the show,
I would be nervous to meet you.
-Ah.
-Because, yeah.
I mean, I'm such a fan.
And I was, like,
so nervous to be around you
and meet you guys and watch you.
But you not only
changed the game
and raised the bar of what
a band can do on the show.
Obviously, Doc Severinsen.
But then, you showed us how to
take it to a next level.
And then I think you changed
the face of comedy as well,
if I may say,
because you would laugh
at a joke --
You told me backstage,
by the way,
for the first two episodes,
they didn't turn your mic on.
-Well, that's another story.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But, when they turned your mic
on and Dave told a joke,
and sometimes the audience
wouldn't really laugh.
But you would go, "Ah."
[ Laughter ]
And that's when you knew
it was funny.
And comedy nerds
around at home are going,
"He's right.
That was a funny joke."
And the audience
just didn't get it yet.
And you just went, "Ah."
-I didn't know
I had that much responsibility,
but I'm thrilled
to hear it though.
-Now, I think because of you,
comedians everywhere,
comedians I know,
they all laugh like you.
-Oh, is that right?
-Every comedian --
Tina Fey laughs like you.
You see a funny joke,
you go, "Ah."
That's you.
-Ah.
-They're doing you.
-[ Laughs ]
-That's Paul Shaffer
right there,
ladies and gentlemen.
I'm honored. Honored.
-Jimmy, I am humbled.
-The honor.
Beyond honored that you're here.
-Well, you know,
remember all of us
looked to Johnny Carson
as our model.
And he used to have
Doc Severinsen at band leader
and Ed on the panel to talk to.
And I used to say, "I'm
a combination of Doc and Ed."
In other words, I'm dead.
[ Laughter ]
Basically, I'm dead.
-That's exactly right, yeah.
-But I'm alive tonight.
-Come on.
I'm happy you're here, bud.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪